SENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY BY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS.
NONE OF THIS MAKE SENSE.
THE DEMOCRAT'S VACCINE POWER
TRIP MADE IT TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER BUT NOT ARE IN THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ENTERING THE
COUNTRY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
POISED TO PUNISH CUSTOM AND
BORDER PATROL AGENTS.
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN JOINS ME.
YOU WERE APPROACHED BY
A WHISTLEBLOWER ON THIS SUBJECT.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
>> THE BORDER PATROL WAS BEGIN
OFFICIAL NOTICE THAT IF AGENTS
DON'T GET THE VACCINE BY
NOVEMBER, THEY WILL BE FIRED.
TODAY WE HAD A BRIEFING FROM
SECRETARY MAYORKAS AND ASKED HIM
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH THE
FLOOD OF MIGRANTS COMING ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
HE SAID WE ASKED THEM IF THEY
WANT IT, IT'S THEIR CHOICE.
THINK ABOUT THAT:
THE PEOPLE BUSTING THEIR TAILS
ENFORCING THE LAW ON THE BORDER,
THEY WILL GET FIRED IF THEY
DON'T TAKE THE VACCINE.
FOR PEOPLE WHO BREAK THE LAW TO
COME HERE, NO BIG DEAL.
IT'S UP TO YOU WANT THAT'S HOW
RIDICULOUS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BECOME AM
THESE PEOPLE WHO JUST A YEAR
LIKE DOCTORS, NURSES AND POLICE
OFFICERS WERE HEROES.
NOW WILL LOSE YOUR JOB IF YOU
DON'T TAKE THE SAME VACCINE THAT
KAMALA HARRIS SAID HE WOULD NOT
TAKE A YEAR AGO.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
>> Laura: WE HAD NURSING
SHORTAGES.
POLICE OFFICERS BEING FIRED.
THEY ARE BRINGING IN FOREIGN
WORKERS TO TAKE THE JOBS OF
AMERICANS WHO DON'T GET THE
VACCINE.
IS THIS REALLY THE COUNTRY WE
WERE BORN IN.
I WANT TO ADD THIS.
EVEN BEFORE THIS WHISTLEBLOWER
NEWS, BORDER PATROL IS ALREADY
SUFFERING FROM PERSONAL
SHORTAGES.
IN A JUNE REPORT THE AGENCY'S
MODEL SHOWED A SHORTAGE OF 1700
OFFICERS AND 400 OTHER
SPECIALISTS.
THIS VACCINE MANDATE WILL HURT
THE HOSPITALS.
IT WILL MAKE THE BORDER LESS
SECURE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT WILL MAKE THE PROBLEM WORSE
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR HOSPITALS
AND POLICE DEPARTMENT HANDLING
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE ONLY CONCLUSION YOU CAN
REACH THIS IS INTENTIONAL.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL WE
WILL STOP BUILDING THE WALL AND
FIRE AGENTS.
IS THAT IS NOT DELIBERATE, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
THIS IS WHAT IS SO SCARY ABOUT
THIS IT ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS WHAT THEY MUST WANT
BECAUSE THERE IS NO OTHER
CONCLUSION ANY RATIONAL PERSON
CAN REACH.
THAT'S FRIGHTENING TO ME AND TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: TRYING TO BRING AS
MANY IN AS POSSIBLE BEFORE THEY
LOSE CONTROL OF CONGRESS.
THE DHS SECRETARY DID MAKE AN
ADMISSION ABOUT MIGRANTS AND
COVID.
>> WE ARE CONFRONTED WITH
A POPULATION OF PEOPLE THAT AS
A DETERMINED MATTER HAVE A RATE
OF ILLNESS OF 20%.
>> Laura: AND WE ARE FIRING
NURSES AND BORDER PATROL AND
POLICE AND TEACHERS.
>> WE ARE GIVING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THE CHOICE WHERE THEY
GET THE VACCINE.
THIS IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY THOUGH
SENSE.
THIS IS THE SAME SECRETARY WHO
A WEEK AND A HALF AGO TOLD US
THE BORDER IS SECURE.
WE ARE SICK OF BEING LIED TO.
WE ARE SICK OF THE FALSE
INFORMATION FROM THE SECRETARY
OF THE STATE SAYING THE BORDER
IS SECURE.
>> Laura: HE WAS PROUD OF HOW IT